do you put value to like
epic throws like singular moments of
greatness
if it's against
um a noteworthy player in a noteworthy
position
there are a lot of highlights of people
that are good judo players but their
highlights are of
you know scrubs yeah on the ijf circuit
but it's like great the japanese guy
threw the guy from
you know
senegal free pwn
great we kind of expected that you took
the world number one against the 330th
person in the world what did you think
was going to happen like when i see
those highlights like thrown around like
social media i'm like
that's not a highlight
they might as well have just been at the
dojo like practice and throws if you
look at the like top 10 list for judo
kano always comes up you know as um
but he's not somebody that i don't think
his results are there but you don't
really know how he
got there
so it's it's hard for me to like i can't
see his judo yeah so i'm not sure kano
by the way is the founder of judo for
people who don't or considered to be the
founder of judo yeah
the sport evolves yeah the players that
are like if you took champions from the
past and you fought them against the
players of today
it's not happening
and that goes with anything right so
every time you think of like who's the
best of all time
it's probably somebody within a
generation or two of today yeah if i'm
gonna pick my
my top three let's say top three and i
would go
generationally speaking
i would pick ono for today
probably iliadus for like
my time frame like the
from a developmental standpoint and then
i'd probably go koga and then before
koga i'd probably go nomura
as like the person of that generation
that people like
as a whole in judo respected
yeah well in the case of uh i wonder if
people feared koga yeah
yeah
like here that that little guy's gonna
get under you and you're gonna go for a
ride you know he was 78 kilos when he
took second at the all japans which is
an open weight class yeah
you know like he
he could throw down with anybody any
weight class and still win he was one of
the early people that planted the seed
uh of judo love of judonia like yeah
and when i looked at him like
that was how like i wanted my judo to be
portrayed that style
yeah
and then elias eliades you just like i
mean you have a similar attitude with
him mm-hmm so you just like the way he
cares that's why we get along
you guys hang out anyway i'd love to see
that conversation i remember when we
were talking about like his coaching i
was like
why didn't you take this team or like
why'd you pick this team and he's like i
can't work with those people like those
people are weak they're children
like they don't know how to train hard
i love that guy
uh what about ono because he was
competing in this olympics he got he got
gold in this olympics right uh
yeah yeah he lost in the team tournament
though i think he just didn't care yeah
he just really wanted to throw that guy
he like throws everybody yeah
so he's he represents the thing you're
mentioning
you